c'est un nouveau mot qui est apparu dans
le petit robert yelle ce pronom et la
contraction de ils et elles couramment
utilisés au sein de la communauté lgbt
il est employé pour désigner une
personne qui ne se reconnaît ni comme
omnicom femme d'une forme neutre donc il
peut s'écrire i l uni 2 l ce mot a été
ajoutée à l'édition numérique du
dictionnaire régulièrement mise à jour
en même temps que vaccinodromes anti
vaccins ou encore pas sanitaires il
pourrait intégrer l'édition papier en
2022 etes-vous pour l'entrée de yale
dans le dictionnaire oui on en met chéri
alors j'ai envie de savoir s'il faut en
penser c'est books alors
oui je veux des hypocrites allez-y les
oui il allait à l'ailé non mais c'est
pas parce qu'un mot existe qu'on est
forcément employé ce mot il a été conçu
pas n'importe quoi parce que
c'est important pour la soirée
oui j'adore c'est pas du prosélytisme ou
du militantisme c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui ne se
sentent ni il nie l
et comment il s'appelle mais il
s'appelle yale voilà donc voilà je ne
dis pas que c'est une bonne chose et
voilà c'est pas on n'est pas pur jeu
sauf que c'est une réalité alors on peut
condamner de la même manière que la
lampe peut évoluer il ya plein de mots
comme gpa pma qui n'existait pas qui
existe maintenant des contractions de la
voilà vous pouvez le condamné à mort
alors je vais prendre un risque n évolue
je vais prendre un risque je fais
intervenir tout de suite isabelle morini
bosc à 19 heures quand c'est un
carrefour de durance
alors profondément moi je m'en fous
d'accord ça démarre mais est en revanche
quand on sait que c'est sous tendu par
toute une mouvance politique qui me
gonfle je te rappelle les fameux broc
maintenant l'on se parle pas de toi j'ai
un avis mais globalement ça saoule
pourtant je suis donc là du coup moi je
suis contre tous tout ce qui les
concerne et parce que quand on soutient
un petit truc qu'on soutient tout nokia
n'y avait pas urgence franchement à
faire ça bon c'était pas ouf mais ça va
mathieu j'aimerais que tu redynamise
tout ça se passait il ya une interview d
qui a été fait par des mercenaires man
qui traîne un peu en ce moment sur
daniel schneidermann voilà deux arrêts
sur image mode arrêt sur image et il
traîne un peu effectivement si vous leur
donnez pas très sympa avec moi ils
étaient au moins un article sur les
voyez vous des tests à bâcher
l'impression mairie alors ça ne me
dérange pas on peut le dire ici j'aime
bien quand même en tout cas ils rétablis
assez incroyable ben ali mais bon il est
bon oui ils commencent par interroger le
dimanche
n'est pas toujours clair c'est pas lui
c'est bon ben moi je me sois quelqu'un
est le mec lui répond qui êtes vous pour
me dire bonjour monsieur bébé parce que
vous avez un attrait monsieur qui vous
dit que je suis un monsieur je peux être
monsieur madame c'est à moi de choisir
eric semaine on en est là quand même
c'est à dire que encore une fois je ne
comprends pas tout ça effectivement
soudé avec du politiquement correct l
approche des élections ou vous faire
plaisir à tout le monde je ne comprends
pas et moi on commence un petit peu pas
vous traite un peu de mots fob cantenac
où vous dites que vous comprenez pas le
nom genre et le nom binaire et tout ça
ça n'a rien à voir c'est juste que à mon
sens il faut aider encore une fois les
gens à se trouver mais en revanche il
faut qu'il ya un moment où on se trouve
je ne
gêne yal d'abord le mot est magnifique
et en plus c'est vraiment incluront dit
l'écriture inclusif ça veut rien dire
mais c'est inclure les gens que chacun
mette à dix prénoms les que chacun soit
concerné là je trouve qu'on est à
l'apothéose de l'humanisme donc je dis
moi maintenant je dirais yale tout le
temps
presse s'ils vous plait ya quelqu'un qui
dit non au oui non
mais qu'on a il faut respecter les
personnes qui se sentent ni homme ni
femme et faut aussi respecter la langue
française la langue française il ya du
masculin et du féminin et puis comment
on va l'utiliser ce mot on va dire i l
est gentil c'est à dire quoi il accorde
au féminin ou masculin en plus il encore
dos masculin on va dire que c'est la
domination des hommes sur la corde au
féminin c'est la domination des femmes
ça n'a aucun sens mais enfin elle
a raison
et on dit quoi aller
je suis d'accord et qui s'appelle bravo
il a rien eu un coup de coeur
[Applaudissements]
médaille même s'il vous plaît mais naïma
mais moi je suis pas contre l'idée
évidemment et bien sûr dans ce que tu
dis bien sûr la langue française elle
d'affaires évolué depuis des siècles des
siècles un problème mais normalement
quand amour entre dans le dictionnaire
c'est parce qu'il est usité met une
gifle extrêmement large or là pour
l'instant c'est encore une minorité
c'est pour ça que dans la nouvelle dans
la nouvelle version du dictionnaire on a
anti vaccins qui n'existait pas on n'a
pas sanitaire qui n'existaient pas peu
une majorité l'utilisent au n était pas
encore présent dans l'affect pour
l'instant ça reste extrêmement
minoritaire donc pour l'instant il n'y a
pas encore de raison pour le faire
rentrer c'est pour ça que moi je mets
encore mon bémol en disant c'est pas
encore le grand exact vous savez quoi le
vrai pour le loyer du petit robert c'est
de se ringardiser qu'ils ont très envie
toujours d'âge envie de faire le grand
richard
ils ont très peur de de disparaître en
réalité deux des mots comme ça trop tout
à fait minoritaire que ça n'existe pas
chez opel shipley on a autant on prend
la parole quand on l'a donnée à ces
hésiter il s'est passé une cité beinheim
l'a dit on va pas réagir là-dessus deux
heures je reste quand on sait
téléspectateurs s'il vous plaît merci
enfin chez guillaume qui a raison oui à
9,8 non eh ben voilà non 90% des
personnes qui sont non favorables voilà
encore une fois gilles verdez vous fait
que voilà